All right. I got the thumbs up. So welcome everyone to
the
Patient Advocate Poster Symposium, Advancing Cancer Research Through
Patient and Community Partnerships and Engagement.
I'm really happy to see everyone here, and I think you'll really enjoy the
session. The session this year is really looking at patient
engagement in different ways, in different
institutions, and ways that patients are engaged, that there's not just one way to
engage. There's not just one area to engage.
And so I hope that you learn a little bit about patient and community engagement
from all of our
panelists. So I'm going to introduce them now, but they're going to get up
one at a time to give their talk.
I'll be the first speaker. I'll introduce myself.
The speaker after me is Michael
Cassaw,
who is the co-founder of the Cure MEC,
and he will be speaking about his organization and some things that they've done in
biobanking.
Kim Newcomer is Senior Director of Research in Colorectal
Cancer Alliance, and she will be talking about some programs that they do in the
CCA. And Lourdes
Baiz Conde-Carbonatti is Associate Director of Community
Outreach and Engagement at
USC, and that's Norris Cancer Center.
And she has amazing programs, and she has three posters, and you need
to see them. And then Annie Ellis will bring us up with--
She's a survivor advocate,
part of the Ovarian Cancer Research Alliance, and she will be talking about
the Matchmakers Grand Challenge.
So it's all different ways where patients have been involved and have
done really cool things in research.
So I'll start off with my talk first.
So I'm a survivor and patient advocate,
and I've been working as a patient advocate at
UNC Chapel Hill.
To start my talk.
I don't see anything here.
I don't have the screen with the talks up here.
It's under Chairperson.
Very left.
Okay.
So I'm Patty Spears, and I'm a patient advocate, and I work at
Lineberger Comprehensive Cancer Center as a patient advocate.
And I'm going to tell you about the program that we have at Lineberger.
I've been there since 2017, and I started there as a research patient
advocate, just doing a
Patient Advocates in Research Council group where we
worked with the researchers and the clinical trialist.
And then in 2019, COE came in. I'm not seeing
slides.
Under
chairperson?
Okay. Okay, they're not seeing my slides, so we're going to change order, and I'll
see what we can do.
But yeah, so I'll introduce Michael, and Michael will come up and give his
talk. You have Michael's talk?
Great. Thank you. Thank you for the opportunity to be here today. Thanks, Patty.
I'd like to begin with a short video that explains why this work matters
so much to my family.
Oh,
bright light, we feel you growing.
We see you glowing.
Oh, bright light.
Oh, white light, we feel you growing.
We see you glowing.
Oh, white light.
Oh, bright light, we feel you
growing.
We see you glowing.
Oh, bright light.
Oh, white light, we feel you growing.
We see you glowing.
Oh,
white light.
Oh, bright light, we feel you
growing.
We see you glowing.
Oh, bright light.
Oh, white light, we feel you growing.
We see you
Oh, bright light, we feel you growing.
We see you glowing.
Oh, bright
light.
Oh, white light, we feel you growing.
We see you glowing.
Oh, white light.
Thank you so much for watching. We share the video not
only to honor our son's journey, but also to honor every
family living with a rare cancer diagnosis
and every person who has dedicated themselves to working in this space.
The researchers, clinicians, funders, people working in
pharma and biotech.
I'm not sure how often you get to engage with the families whose work your
work is impacting, but what I want to say to you is
this.
In our darkest hours and years, it is your work that is carving a window of
light for families like ours to hope and dream in.
In just two weeks, our beautiful son Sebas will turn seven years old.
He still has four nodules in his lungs that are being monitored very closely,
but we're deeply grateful that they've been stable for a year,
and we don't take a single day of that for granted.
For us,
it means another day to fight.
MEC affects both children and adults and is considered ultra-rare.
The soft tissue version that Sebas has is even more rare, with just a handful of
new cases each year in the US.
In 2021, when Sebas was diagnosed, virtually nothing was known about
MEC. There were no treatment protocols, no clinical trials, and no
researchers focused on the disease.
With 11 nodules in his lungs, we were told his prognosis was poor.
It felt like stepping into darkness.
But what gave us hope, what kept us moving, were other rare cancer
patients and families who had walked similar paths before us.
In the rare cancer world, patients and families are often the drivers of
change.
Over the past four years, we've learned that the challenge isn't just a lack of
treatments. It's also the lack of the conditions that make research
possible.
Too few samples, too little data, too few disease models,
too little coordination, too little funding.
And that's why my wife Naomi and I co-founded Curemec from Sebas's
hospital bed.
One of the most important things we've learned,
both in rare cancer and in my work as an environmental advocate, is that
relationships are not separate from the work.
Very often, they're what get it moving.
One of Curemec's most important early contributions has been the partnerships and
relationships we have helped cultivate between patient advocacy groups,
clinicians, foundations, and researchers.
And these relationships have led to exciting new collaborations, model
sharing, scientific publications, inclusion
of MEC in broader research efforts, and a growing willingness amongst
partners to share information, tools, and expertise.
And what feels both humbling and deeply hopeful to us is the team
that has come together around this work.
These are extraordinary scientists, people doing truly
innovative and groundbreaking research.
And what moves us the most is not only that they are willing to work with us,
but that they are willing to work together.
One example of that involves Dr. Ryan Roberts at Nationwide Children's and
Dr. Taran Gujral at Fred Hutch.
Dr. Roberts developed the world's only MEC PDX model and
has been willing to share it.
Dr. Gujral, who I had met at a Target Cancer symposium in Boston,
developed an innovative systems pharmacology platform through his TRACER
initiative and was willing to apply it to MEC.
When those two pieces came together, a new opportunity opened up to test
therapies and better understand the disease.
And it's been this kind of generosity and willingness to work together that has
shaped this entire journey for us.
Because what we've learned is that progress in rare cancers rarely begins with
a large research initiative or a major grant.
It begins with people,
with conversations, with scientists and funders who are willing to
ask, "How can I help?"
Last year at AACR, I met two researchers who asked that question and have since
taken on MEC.
Dr. Ryan New and his team conducted a retrospective study of 70 MEC
patients at MD Anderson. And Dr. Elena
Vasileva, now at Children's National, recently developed the
first-ever genetic zebrafish model of MEC.
That same spirit has shaped our partnership with funders.
While our organization doesn't have enormous resources, we've tried to
use every dollar we've raised as leverage.
That has included partnering with larger foundations such as the RALLY
Foundation and St. Baldrick's to co-fund MEC research projects,
the first ever MEC-specific research grants ever awarded.
And through our partnership with the Rare Cancer Research Foundation, we
recently launched the first-ever MEC Biobank and Data Commons,
critical resources that give patients and families a meaningful way to contribute
to research by donating tumor tissue and sharing their
medical histories.
By building this infrastructure, we're making it easier for scientists to access
the biospecimens and data they need to better understand MEC and
explore new treatment possibilities.
Together, these relationships and collaborations are helping lay the
foundation for the first integrated research ecosystem for
myoepithelial carcinoma.And this
brings me to my closing ask.
First, we need to connect with more MEC patients and families.
Second, we need more biospecimens and associated clinical data,
including fresh tissue, cryopreserved and frozen tissue,
FFPE samples, and sequencing data.
Access to samples remains one of the biggest barriers to progress.
And third, we need more scientific partners, researchers willing to
apply their tools, models, platforms, and ideas to this disease.
If you're an oncologist or work in
a hospital and can talk to the
pathologists at your institution if they've ever seen MEC or if they have any
samples, this could have an enormous impact on our efforts.
With an ultra-rare cancer, every sample we find is invaluable to the work.
If you think you might be able to help us either find samples or data, or if you
want to collaborate, please come find me after the talk, or you can scan the
QR code on the screen. We've created a simple form where you can let us know
how you might be able to help. It would really mean the world to me to
connect to you.
My family is a soccer family. Both of my sons play, and I played
for most of my life.
Soccer is often called the most beautiful game, and one reason
is that it's built on teamwork.
No single player can carry the ball all the way to the goal every time.
It takes passing, coordination, trust, and a shared
sense of purpose.
Rare cancer research is no different.
In MEC, we need patients and families, scientists and clinicians,
pathologists and funders all working together,
each contributing in different ways but advancing towards the same goal.
And that's what partnership looks like.
It's how we move the ball forward. And for rare cancers like MEC, it's
the only way we're going to make progress.
And here's what I wouldn't have said just a year ago.
Standing here today, I truly believe that this team we are
building is going to win the cup.
The only questions are, in what timeframe?
Who else is going to be with us? And what will we have learned along the way?
Not only about MEC science, but about what becomes possible
when people choose to work together in a radically collaborative type of
way,
and how we will carry those lessons forward in the work we do, both
professionally and personally.
Because if we want to change the future for patients with MEC, we
are only going to do it the way great teams do it,
together,
moving the ball forward one pass at a time.
Thank you.
So we'll take a few questions if you want, one or two questions.
I have a question for you. So, this was really moving.
I think this is really something, seeing parents and patients
do this, really promoting rare diseases
to the forefront and getting the research done.
So,
what did you think your biggest barrier is now?
You've gotten this started, you've gotten a foot in the door
type of thing, and a lot of things going on.
What do you think your biggest challenge is today?
Thanks for the question. I think one of the biggest barriers, as I mentioned
in my presentation, is access to specimens.
We really need any kind of specimen we can find.
Even one specimen is going to make the difference for us.
The PDX model and other models are critical to our work
as well. The PDX is the only model that currently
exists.
And thankfully, thanks to Dr. Vassileva, now we have a genetic
zebrafish model as well. So, I think access to
specimens is the biggest
barrier that we have at this time. The other thing is that we need to connect with
more patients. So if any of you know oncologists who can
at least give that patient our website, hopefully they'll
connect with us. Because that's the only way that we are going to advance this
work, is by building a community of MEC patients and families so that we can all
work together to find a cure for this disease.
Thank you.
Anybody else? Thank you.
Okay, so I think now we can move on to my presentation.
Let's try it. We've got some gremlins in the room, but I think we're getting over
it, so we'll see.
Okay, that's it. And I have another slide after that,
so very good. So I did a little introduction of myself already, and I'm
in the Community Outreach and Engagement Office at Lineberger Comprehensive
Cancer Center, and we began this program called Lineberger Excellence in
Advocacy Program. And I'll give you a little background
onWhy we did it and how we did it and how we operate
today,
and how we engage advocates, community members, and patients and
caregivers in all of the research and clinical trials that go on at
Lineberger.
And it takes a village. It definitely does.
And community outreach and engagement offices at comprehensive cancer centers are
godsend for me. I was alone at the university just doing a patient research
advocacy group by myself for a couple of years, and then COE came
along. We affectionately call it COE, came along, and they
got a community advisory board, and I kind of joined up with them.
And now there's a whole office of us that do these things.
And these are just some of the people that engage with our patient and our
advocates in the community and bring science to the community and the
community to science. Jennifer Potter leads this program.
She's the director. She's actually a survivor as well.
And Veronica is my go-to for community anything.
And then we have all different staff members, and they're really absolutely
awesome. So it takes a village. And this is what I feel like
we do at Lineberger and at COE. This is my vision, is we
bring sensitivity and awareness of the patient and community
into Lineberger, into the cancer center by doing in-reach.
And then we really want our researchers to go out to the community somehow, whether
it's through social media or boots on the ground
to get the word out about the research being done at the cancer
center. And we create these partnerships.
COE is partnership driven, and they really partner not only with
patients and community members, but organizations all over the state.
We cover the entire state of North Carolina.
So we can ensure a patient is research centered.
And so, we started having all these boards and councils, and you go to these
places and there's all these things going on.
And we realized that we really needed to bring everyone together under one umbrella
to really organize everyone and make sure everything was equitable and
everybody got what they needed. And we weren't
jumping all over each other. So we had the PFAC, the PARC, the CAB, the
SCISAB, all these different things going on. Right?
So what we decided to do was bring it all under one umbrella.
So we have an umbrella,
and we call it the Lineberger Excellence and Advocacy Program, where we can do
recruitment to everything. We can do training.
We have a lot of training. We can do engagement.
We can make sure compensation is equitable across all of our councils and
boards, and we can assess what's going on, because we keep track of
everything now, because COE tracks everything.
They're a metrics
part of it. And integration into the cancer center is
key, because COE kind of sits over here, but we really need to integrate it
within the cancer center, and there's so many ways that we do that.
And we integrate patient and community members into research through councils,
projects, grants, things like that.
We integrate into the hospital with advisory boards, hospital
boards, where they have a patient advocate on grand rounds every
time they have grand rounds every month, education projects.
And then we really concentrate on that translational component as well.
Me and Laurie, who's sitting in the audience, sit on the protocol
review committee together. We review the protocols, then we review the
consents. We
sit on teams. We do patient materials. We review patient materials.
It's just a lot that you can do within a cancer center, and I think just really
putting that down on paper is really important.
And we feel like having opportunities builds relationships with our patient and
community members, and that's how we're really going to promote trust between
the cancer center and the community, which is so needed these days.
And so who are our LEAP advocates? We have our councils and
boards, but we also have a block over here of LEAP advocates, a pool.
So we can bring in advocates from all over the state that are not on boards and
councils, and they can have the same opportunities that everybody else
has to kind of volunteer and get more involved and maybe become a
member of a council or board. And that's our demographics down here, which
is not that bad. We have 27% African American, which is
typical for North Carolina. And then we try to cover the
entire state. Of course, we're concentrated in the triangle area, but we have some
outlying areas that have advocates and community members as well.
And one of the things that we can do, since we kind of organize all together,
is we can really track engagement.
And we have a cool way of researchers-- I just had a researcher email me,
"Oh, my student is doing a DoD," or, "My postdoc is doing a DoD.
How can they get an advocate?" Well, I can give them a link to a form.
So I say, "Okay, have her fill out this form." It's a structured form about
project, compensation, timing, how much time they
need, what other requirements, DoD has lots of
requirements, requirements that you need.
We send that out to all of our advocates, which is over 90 advocates, and then
they respond as volunteers, and we send the volunteers to the researcher
and make that connection. And we've been doing that for a year
or two now. And so we've had 86 requests and over 250
responses to those requests. And we can track the type of request.
One of the things we've done since 2001, since I've been there, is every
research grant, the pilot research grant at Lineberger that's submitted is
reviewed by an advocate or community member, and now PFAC members.
I have everybody review now. And we've reviewed over
328 grants, and that's included
36 individual advocates.
And we train. So this is the brainchild of Laurie Betz, who's sitting in the
audience, came to SSP and said, "We need to do some kind of
training for our advocates." So we started this after she
came to SSP, and it's called the ASPIRE program, and we've had actually 10
lectures. We just had one last week.
We had an AI lecture on the ethics of AI.
And I haven't seen it yet because I wasn't able to, but it's on our learning
portal. But we engage our scientists, our surgeons.
Phil Spanheimer is our surgeon, talk about surgery.
And we have them give lectures to our advocates, and it's sent out to all of
our pool of advocates. And so we really try to keep them educated.
And we have peer events at the end. We have those once a year, and we're coming up
on our fifth one will be in October....
in our learning portal. So we decided that we really needed a way to share these
videos and everything with our advocates.
But advocates do not have access to OneDrive,
period, end of story. And I don't-- It's horrible.
So we actually had our IT people and our training people set up
an anonymous website. So it's an anonymous link.
It won't show up on anybody's search, but if you have the link, you can get on the
site without a password, which really helps our advocates a lot.
And I actually have things in there for our researchers as well, and I send them
the link on how to engage advocates and how to
start a letter of support for your advocate, things like that.
But for grant review, I do a video of the trainings that I do and put
it up there with the slides. They can easily get at any resources that we have and
the new documents on all of the things that you need to know to review grants.
So they don't have to go to the right email.
They can just go to the portal and find it, and it's been really helpful.
It's helpful for me. I
hope it's helpful for them. But one of the things that I really like and
that COE is really good at is really trying to evaluate what
we're doing with this engagement. Right?
So since we have the form that people fill out and we do the
matching, we know who the researchers are, and we know who the advocates are, and
we can send out evaluations. And we can ask them questions about, "So
how did that go?" So we do this every year.
We've done it in 2024, 2025, and we're getting ready to do
2026 in May,
actually. And we ask them
questions on a form, the Likert scale, and we can track over time how
things are going, and I'll show you some of the things that we track.
So these are the things that I like to track the most, and one of the
questions is, or three of the questions are, "Do you feel your opinions were
heard,
respected, valued?"
And then they can do always, greater than 50%, or less than that.
But we've been in the upper 90 range of the always and greater than
50%, which I think is pretty good, and we can track that over time as
well. And then other things we put on there, and Maya
Roberson is also on all of our committees as
an advisor, and she suggested some of these questions
as, "In your engagement, did you believe that the power was
shared, that decisions were transparent, and projects were
updated timely?" Which we really want to keep track of that as we go.
Do we have to train-- I do some training of the researchers as well as the training
of the advocates, but we need to do that.
And
we want to track, are we bugging them too much with these emails of opportunities
or not enough?
And so we're kind of keeping track of that as well.
And then,
did it meet your expectations? I think one of the things that's hard about
advocacy are,
so do we expect less from them than they think or more?
And so that's something that we track as well.
And then, these are just some pictures, but we think the impact is really
huge. I think that it really brings the research and clinical trials to
be more patient-centered because they learn more about patients.
But I really think one of the valuable things that happens is our
patient and community members become really vested in the science and
the research. And we had
an
appreciation dinner the other night.
Here's our picture from just two Saturdays ago.
I met Tori there for the first time.
But we had a guest speaker of Dr. Shelley Earp, right?
So he's amazing. And after he spoke, one of our advocates said,
"You just put a hug around research." And he did.
He put a hug around research. Because I think it's important for us to
really bring our community and patient members in
to really let them value research more.
I think with being silent-- We can't be silent with them.
We need to really share a lot with them and be transparent.
So,
that's all that I have. Thank you.
Are there any questions, or...
I can't ask myself a question, so
I'll invite up Kim.
Oh, we have a question.
Oh, is there a question? Oh.
I noticed on your, I believe it was the second slide,
that it showed 83% female, 17% male.
Was that the cancer population that you reach out to?
What was that percentage referring to?
That was our advocate population.
The advocate population.
Mm-hmm.
Is prostate cancer very low in--
Does prostate cancer get
significant attention from the-
We actually have a whole men's health project.
Oh, I see.
So one of the people, Will, on the right side, he does
the prostate cancer outreach. And we do men's health all the time.
But he just came on board. But we had a group that did men's health,
but now he really is concentrating on that.
Excellent.
And hopefully we'll get more male
advocates involved in that, because we have a
significant number, but not enough, definitely.
Thank you.
Something like that.
I just have a two-part question.
Your advocacy program,
does it have any sort of reporting
component to it for telling the
community
any level of advocacy, or that if there's a
variety of levels of advocacy that a
person can look towards if this is something they're
attracted to?
And then the second half of that would be,
is there any way to
correlateadvocacy
to the measurement of health intelligence or health
literacy. Because part of the problem that we're trying to
overcome in research and making everyone comfortable with
research is that health illiteracy
is very prevalent, and it's the biggest hurdle that we're all trying to
overcome. So I'd like to hear how you all address that in your program.
Yeah. We haven't even done any outreach to get advocates
in type of thing. It's really just natural, but we will be, in
the future, probably doing something like that.
But we treat all advocates pretty equal, and that's what I like to do.
Whether you're
a patient advocate working directly with patients, or a
community member in a nonprofit, or a research advocate, we treat
everybody pretty similarly.
And then your second question...
Health literacy.
Huh?
Health literacy. So actually, as part of my advocacy team, we have a health
literacy expert as part of my team.
She works in the library, and she is on all of my other
teams, and any kind of material that we put out for patients
goes through her,
actually. Yeah. So we'll take one more question probably.
Yeah. Because we'll have a time at the end to ask more questions.
Can you talk a little bit about how you scoped and really developed a training
program that was both useful and not too broad for
Lineberger's needs as far as the advocacy training?
So how successful the trainings are?
How you developed that scope so that it was tailored to the institution so that the
training wasn't too broad or non-specific enough for advocates to be useful in
their roles.
Yeah. So,
any training that I do, whether it's with researchers or advocates, I do an
evaluation after and say, "Was this useful and was
this helpful?" type of thing. And like for the grant training, it's for
specific things. But for our SPIRE program, I think we're going to institute
more of that, where we're saying, "Is this the right level?
Is this the right thing?" And we always ask them what they want to
hear about. So we sent out a survey and said, "What are you interested in?
What do you want to hear about?" So the four lectures this year came directly
from that survey,
the top four things. But I think there needs to be more ways for us to evaluate
the impact of that on their volunteerism.
Because I always ask them if they feel prepared for grant review after
they do the training.
Right. Thank you.
So, okay. So I think we'll move on to Kim.
I'm here to talk to you today about what happens when you stop treating patients
like subjects of research and start treating them as architects of it.
Hi, everyone. I'm Kim Newcomer, and I'm the senior director of research
programs at the Colorectal Cancer Alliance.
And I'm also an 18-year survivor of Stage 4 rectal cancer.
I was diagnosed at 35. Don't do the math.
But it really drives my passion for this work.
I've been at the Alliance for about nine years now, and I focus on
advancing our adaptive clinical trial to launch.
I'm also working on engaging with our scientific
leaders and supporting some of our initiatives, like our biomarker project
and our RFP and research portfolio.
Just a little bit about the Alliance as we get started.
The Alliance is a nonprofit. It was founded in 1999 by a
group of volunteers, and the organization is based in Washington,
DC, with our staff, volunteers, and initiatives
nationwide. The Alliance's key initiative is Project Cure
CRC, which is accelerating science towards
cures.
Colon cancer stands alone because it's both common, deadly,
preventable, underfunded, all at the same time.
It affects more than 150,000 people in the US each year.
It kills more than 50,000 people each year, making it the second deadliest
cancer in the United States.
It's also highly preventable. Screening can interrupt that polyp to
cancer process, and it's estimated 68% of
all colon cancer deaths can be avoided with a one-time screening.
And yet it remains under-recognized, underfunded,
and underfunded relative to its burden.
The number I do want to leave you with right now is the five-year survival
rate for metastatic colorectal cancer, which is 13%.
That number is the reason why Project Cure CRC exists.
And this is just a little bit of fun.
So we all know that awareness is the front end of research
pipeline.
We have this really fun campaign called Lead From Behind.
It's been our most successful campaign for
awareness, using humor, celebrity voice,
and really culture to break the stigma around colorectal cancer.
With campaigns with Ryan Reynolds, Katie Couric,
Terry Crews, Dax Prescott has helped us reach people
traditional health messaging doesn't reach.
And just a little bit of breaking news.
The Alliance won a Webby, which is, I think they won it today for our
Katie Couric campaign, and I was told that it is very
similar to the Oscar
on the internet. So, very exciting news.
One way we make our ecosystem real is through clinical
navigation. The Alliance provides free certified patient navigators
for patients and families across the full cancer journey.From
diagnosis to biomarker testing to treatment options, clinical trial
access, insurance barriers, and survivorship.
It's not only support service, it's research infrastructure.
Every time a navigator identifies a barrier, whether it's insurance,
transportation, access to biomarker testing, or confusion about
trial options, it
becomes valuable information. This navigation helps
patients get better care, and it helps us understand where the system is
breaking down.
In other words, navigations turn barriers into data and data into real
action.
We
do work in biomarker. Our equity work is grounded in our biomarker,
ClearCRC,
Colorectal Cancer Equity and Impact.
This initiative is focused on addressing racial, ethnic, geographic,
and socioeconomic disparities in colorectal cancer outcomes.
We know underserved communities face barriers to screening, biomarker
testing, and trial participation.
So ClearCRC is designed to meet people where they are,
improve access to testing, and reduce disparities and study
what works.
Equity is not a side effort in this model, but it's built into the design.
And this is one of my fun ones. So we're getting down to
business now. The CureCRC Summit.
This summit brings together researchers, clinicians, patients, advocates, and
industry, and also policy leaders around one shared
goal, which is accelerating cures.
This is where collaboration becomes operational.
This is not just a meeting about
colorectal cancer.
It's part of the infrastructure that helps move the field forward.
Together, these stakeholders are not just imagining a better future, they're
building one.
A little bit about Project Cure. It's built on three
pillars. First, improving the five-year survival rate for
metastatic colorectal cancer, which, if you remember, I said that is
13%. Our goal is to raise that to 35,
nearly a three time improvement in five years.
Second is to fast track new therapies to bedside through the Alliance's
adaptive clinical trial platform.
And third, to accelerate cures through Blue Lake,
which will be the world's largest colorectal cancer registry and data platform.
Now, these pillars reinforce one another.
Better patient data leads to better targets, leads to better
leads, leads to better trials. Better trials lead to better
outcomes.
And now, Project Cure has several components that have not previously been combined
in colorectal cancer that are being brought together for
one coordinated system. We have our adaptive
clinical trial platform,
Blue Lake, which generates real world data by connecting
clinical, genomic, and patient-reported data,
BlueHQ, which provides navigation, engagement, and patient
support, all while generating real-time information on patients' needs and
barriers,
and our RFP, which is our competitive funding
program to support investigators who work, feeds back into the system.
This is the innovation. The innovation about not just the parts, it's the
combination of all four.
And my next slide shows
the real heart of the model.
At the top are the patients, on the bottom left is the data,
in the bottom right are the treatments.
Connecting them all are our three platforms, BlueHQ, Blue Lake,
and the adaptive clinical trial.
Oops. Okay, here we go. Sorry about that.
This effort is being led by highly respected colorectal cancer investigators
from institutions across the country, including University of Colorado,
MD Anderson, City of Hope, UCSF,
Vanderbilt, Mass Gen, Georgetown, and others.
This matters because this is not advocacy standing beside
science. It's rigorous science built with a patient partnership at the center.
Our adaptive clinical trial is built around multiple treatment windows that
reflect distinct biological states of colorectal cancer.
These are the neoadjuvant, peri-op, minimal
residual disease with no evidence of disease, and refractory Stage IV.
Each window represents a different biology
and a different unmet need.
And importantly, these were not selected by researchers alone.
Patients helped shape which window mattered most.
That means this platform reflects both scientific opportunity and
lived urgency.
Excuse me. We also have our consortium.
The consortium brings together industry, researchers, patients, and advocates, and
physicians in a formal governance. That distinction really matters.
Most organizations consult patients.
This model gives patients governance.
Patients are not included because it looks good.
They are included because the science is better when they help shape
priorities, protocol design, and implementation.
That is a real, meaningful partnership.
And here's just some of our results.
We received over 525 proposals. We have
distributed over $15 million in...
Actually, it's 34 projects in the past two years, and we have over
150 investigators engaged and 20 industry
partners also involved.
So we're on our
way.Let's
see. So
I think I went over that already. So we built something that's really never
existed before this disease, but we built it with patients,
not just for them. I hope this changes how you think
about the next study you design. And really, thank you to Patty
Spears
for chairing this session, and thank you to AACR's committee for this opportunity.
And I have a little bit of a video
that I think is going to play in the background. It is.
You don't have to watch it all, but this is some of the research we funded.
This is part of the $11 million research we funded this year.
So I'm just highlighting some of our scientists.
Thank you, Kim.
If you have any questions for Kim about this
great endeavor that they've started
-
We're just doing one or two things
... which is amazing, you can walk up to mic.
I'll ask her the first question that I ask.
This is a great opportunity for colorectal cancer-
Right
... actually, to do this platform trial.
How many advocates do you have involved, and what do you-
Oh my goodness
... envision in the future as well?
This is a good question.
Yeah.
Right now, we have our consortium.
We also have a patient council. We
invite all volunteers to take part of
Project Cure CRC. The more voices that are involved, the more people that are
involved, the more money we can raise.
We all know that research takes money, so I'm sure if
anyone wants to be part of that, we would welcome it.
But yeah, we love our volunteers, and we have about
12,000 volunteers right now. So not all are part of this, but we
would welcome as many as would want to be involved.
Okay, good.
Okay, thank you, Kim.
Yeah.
I got a question.
Okay. All right.
Got to fix that mic.
Hope I didn't go too long.
Yeah, we'll get the mic later, I guess.
I'm a colorectal cancer survivor myself.
Amazing.
It is. I'm glad to be here.
My question, though, is about
your
program and organization. Is there any
intention to reach out to the more
than 96
FDA-certified manufacturers of
over-the-counter colorectal tests that
are presently offered in the marketplace?
I know two manufacturers who are doing a great job
with it, a FIT2 kind of test,
immunochemical.
Oh, he's talking about prevention.
We do work with-
Yeah.
Yes, we do work with Exact and Guardant and
everyone who's doing the FIT tests and
all the testing as well. All that information is on our
website as well. I think some of our campaigns with Lead From Behind,
we were talking about FIT tests, and we work with them as much as we can,
especially in underserved communities, to really get those tests out.
Yeah.
Talk to you after.
Yeah, we'll talk later.
And there's someone else.
Anyone else have a question?
Yeah. Just one.
She has the tall microphone.
Oh, okay. I'm sorry. I'm short. I can't see that far.
We should've traded them out.
Really, really impressive work and platform.
Can you talk a little bit about the timeline from strategic
vision to-
Okay, yes
... operations?
Very exciting. So
I'm looking at my CEO. Can I say?
So we are very close. The protocol is written. We are ready.
Hopefully have first patient in by end of year
in our adaptive clinical trial platform.
We
have a version of BlueHQ right now.
We're still building that out, and Blue Lake will be building that out as well.
But if we had $200 million, we could build it all right now.
But we all know that it takes time and funding.
So,
like I said, our CEO is back there if anyone wants to
donate to it.
You always have to try, right?
But yes, we're planning to launch our trial by end of year.
Thank you.
Yes, wherever she went.
Okay, great.
And our next speaker is Lourdes, or Dr.
Basconde-Garbarnati.
Hi. Good afternoon, everybody. Thank you all for being here.
I'm Lourdes Basconde-Garbarnati, and I am really
pleased to be here. Part of my motivation for being here is
I'm that kind of kid who probably was really
disturbing when you were a young parent, for example, because I
kept asking why, and I kept asking why to the
why, and again, why. And so I keep asking
why. And so part of my passion behind all of this is why
do we see the inequities that we see?
What is happening, and why do some
people don't have the advantages that other people have, and how does
that impact all of our different communities?
And so that drives a lot of what I do. It's that why.
So I'm going to tell you a little bit of...
These are my disclosures. I work at Norris at USC,
and I do get funding from Genentech, NCI, and
NIMHD. And I'm also chair of a board of directors of the National
Alliance for Hispanic Health, which oversees the health of 15 million
Hispanics nationwide in over 200 community-based
organizations.
This is our team, both the leadership and some of the members that
work with us. And today, I'm going to talk about our program that
is a bicoastal program that goes from Florida all the way
to California, and it's our
California/Florida Cancer Research Education and Engagement
Health Center Community Outreach Core.
And some of the work that we do there, I think, highlights a lot of the work that
we do with our patient advocatesSo, as you well know,
striking disparities continue to exist, especially in mortality,
in priority cancers. And again, why?
Why are there these disparities? Why are there these differences?
And so we've set out to try to alleviate some of those
differences. We know that there's a high percentage of lifestyle-driven
cancers, which means that most are technically preventable through
behavior changes like smoking cessation, improved diet,
limiting alcohol, and also we're dealing with a lot of environmental cues,
and each day, we find more and more relationship with
risk factors from the environment, whether it's pesticide in the foods that
we eat, when we're recommending fruits and vegetables, and then we have to make
sure people are washing them really well.
It's not just a recommendation, but how do we qualify these things?
Our patient advocates are tackling, in Norris as
well as at Florida, some of the most difficult
problems in research engagement.
So there was one of my whys. Why aren't people participating
at the level that they need to be? How do we engage them, and how can we make
sure that they are part of the solution in really reducing
morbidity and mortality? So our patient advocates and
survivors are really contributing, and they have let us know very
clearly that there's a lack of access to trusted information.
There are gaps in communication that have not been bridged in spite of
everything that we're doing. There's right now a real distrust for
science, and so how do we bring science back into the heart of
what we do and really regain that trust in science?
There's lack of culturally and in language information and lack of available
resources to navigate the entire healthcare system.
If you have cancer,
you well know that the moment they say those words,
your heart stops, your mind stops.
And so imagine navigating an entire system when you can't
speak the language, when you don't know where to go, and you don't know where the
resources are. And that's where we need advocates like
yourselves who are here and people to help organize
so that we can all hang together. I really like what our first speaker
said today. It really takes all of us together to be able to do this.
Our community core has an active tri-institutional,
bi-directional community advisory board, which really
participates in a lot of our activities, and I'll let you know, this is a
picture of our advisory board. They meet on a quarterly basis.
They contribute information. They engage other individuals through
social media. They participate in training and activities, but more
importantly, they serve in a bi-directional guidance on the
research.
Some of our researchers will come to our meetings
to pitch an idea of what they're thinking about for their
research. And our advocates are able to ask the hard
questions. Well, what does that mean?
And who is it going to be for? And are you going to keep it in a journal
somewhere, or how are you going to get it back to us?
And so those are really key questions that are really
important for our patient advocates.
They support the co-creation of educational materials, and I'll show you
a few pieces in a few minutes. And they
ensure that that perspective
of the patient advocates is really embedded in
the research that we do.
We do short community supporters academy trainings, which happen
any time during the year. They could be one hour, two hours, and they
happen at different times. But we also have a 10 weeks academy
to work with community scientists, which are our patient advocates, to train
them on research and also train our researchers on
the expertise that these patient advocates have.
And they get paid $1,000 for participation.
So it's not just like,
come and everybody's volunteering.
We actually pay them for their work, and we provide motivation and
support for them to do their own patient advocacy programs
that are then embedded in the community.
And then we hold a cancer conference every year, which is Cancer
in the Community.
Our program is, I mentioned, 10 weeks, and the curriculum
addresses these cancer health differences, the why.
It's social determinants of health, the why.
The policy, the why. The ethics, the why,
especially now with AI and all of these. There are lots of questions about ethics.
Genomics and community-based participatory research.
And also, all of our sessions are bilingual because in Los Angeles, we have, for
example, a very large Hispanic population, and if you are
monolingual, you may not be able to participate, yet you may have something
important to say as well. And so we actually have translators
in Mandarin and Korean and also in
Spanish that come to our meetings, regular meetings, so that
those individuals from those communities can also participate at a
higher level. Here are some of our community scientists, research
ambassadors. In the training program, we conduct lab tours
so that our community scientists go into the labs
themselves. They see what happens to your tissue once
you give a sample. What actually happens from the moment that
comes out of your body, all the way to how it contributes to the
research.We also do training materials which are
produced with
our patient advocates, and they include toolkits and a variety
of other products. This is Pastor Rhonda
Holbert. She leads one of the cancer ministries
and with
hundreds of Black churches that work with her on these
issues, going out and talking about women's cancer.
And so she's led nine episodes of a podcast that she
leads. We also do work out in the community
with our community navigators, and they're a little different than the actual
patient navigators because our community navigators are out there
providing education, providing information.
And through our community navigators, just last year, we were able to
identify 149 individuals who were
symptomatic and were scared and had not gone to the doctor,
and we were able to bring them in and follow them through.
So we're collaborating with our communities, trying to
prevent and to get there when it's early on.
We conduct a series of events, including with the Orlando Magic,
we partner with, in order to reach people where they're at,
especially men, because I think I loved your question that you asked
about the differences. And so we're trying to go where people are
at to get the information. This is other pictures of that.
We also, as you well know,
there's a lot of food insecurity in some of our communities.
And when we're telling people to eat better,
we are telling people to eat better, people who don't have anything to eat.
And so let's start from the beginning.
How do we reach out to these folks? So we have
organized ourselves with the YMCAs, and there's 26, for
example, in Los Angeles that we work with in different communities.
And
during the pandemic, for example, we provided food in 22
different cities. So there's another why.
Why are people maybe not eating better?
Well, maybe we need to ask some hard questions as to what is
happening in these communities. We're also doing more work
on biospecimen donations, trying
to inform and let people know what this is about.
We produced a video with our basic scientists on that,
and we engage them through different ways.
Good morning.
And then we've also developed a series of very short
films, and I'm going to do really quick little clips so that you could see.
These are our patient advocates that are patients themselves telling
their little stories about what's happened to them, and these have been ways that
we're finding are really getting to people directly.
This is Sergio, who's a beekeeper, and so you'll just hear a little bit about
him, and I'm going to do some very quick ones so that you could see just a
couple.
Good morning. I'm Sergio Juarez. One day, I felt a
terrible pain on my left side. I didn't sleep at all that night,
couldn't take the pain anymore. I went to the general hospital, and
after some tests, they told me, "You have cancer, and we
need to operate." I felt bad.
They did the surgery. In that moment, my life took a
360-degree turn.
This is another one.
At some point, I felt sick.
The doctors came to my room. They asked me how I was feeling.
"We don't have good news," was the first thing that they told me.
I told them, "Don't worry. I'll accept what you tell me." They told me,
"Well, ma'am, we have to intervene immediately.
It's colorectal cancer." My husband was there, and two of my
children were with me.
So I explained the situation to them.
Remember that the word cancer is dramatic and very
painful, but I have a lot of strength.
I told them that everything was going to be fine, that I felt fine.
The first question I really asked was, "How did everything go?"
I was told that everything was fine, to be calm.
There were studies and biopsies to be done.
I still answered, "Do what you have to do.
I am in the best hands." For all of us in the family,
Lynch syndrome was something we had never heard of.
And so our patients help to explain some of these
very complex concepts by telling their
own story. And so it comes from a genuine
heart-to-heart kind of conversation explaining some of the more complex
issues. We are really proud of this. Dr.
Marianna Stern, who is
part of our group, she is the chair of the
2026 cancer report coming out of AACR, and
three of our CAB members are going to be
featured, and they're coming to their homes to
take their stories and bringing them to
Congress. Talk about patient advocacy at a really, really
high level. And so we're really proud of their work.
We train them. We work with them. We build capacity,
and we also need to build the capacity of others and our investigators
as well to work with them. So this is something that's going to be
happening, and you'll see that once the cancer report is out.
So we also have all of these metrics, and Patty, I'm contacting you about some of
your metrics. Which I will come out to do.
But I'm going to jump now to some of our conclusions.
We've really provided opportunities for patient advocates to tell their
stories. We strengthened our patient advocates' knowledge.
They have led with their experiences.
They've optimized our research, our outreach, and our engagement.
They've helped us build much stronger community academic partnerships,
increased research participation, fostered community
capacity, strengthened communication with scientists, and
promoted participation in cancer.
And now I will ask you, what is your why, and how are you going to
make sure that that gets answered and whether it's why or
why not?
Thank you.
Any questions?
We're open for questions, and I think Kim has the first question.
Sorry, I'll just-
Come to the microphone if you have a question.
Can you tell me a little bit more about your community navigators and how do
you find them, and do you partner with local health clinics?
How do you-
Yes. So our community navigators, are usually
community health workers out from the community identified
right from the communities that we work with.
For the Hispanic community, for example, we work with Promotores de Salud, which is
a little bit of a different model. But all of these community workers are
trained. Right now, we have about 45 that have been trained,
in the different communities, and they are out there all the
time doing pop-up events, doing different kinds of activities and
events. And so they're the ones that are out there, like the front line of
defense. People come to them at just any event.
It doesn't have to be a health fair.
We're at any event that we can think of that we could show up, whether
it's Chinese New Year or something else.
And most of them speak the language of the communities that we're in,
and so it makes it easier for them to be approached and to talk
about some of this thing. They go through training with us, and they
get also paid for that. And many of them are also patient
advocates or survivors themselves.
Can I follow up real quick? One quick question. I promise, Patty, really quick.
Sure.
And do you also partner with other local nonprofits?
Yes. Yes, we do. So we have, actually, we have,
42 active partnerships right now in the community that we are
working with a variety of community-based organizations.
Unfortunately, in recent times, many of those are starting to
fold or have folded, because of the funding environment,
and so we're trying to see ways that we can support them.
We're very fortunate that we have, amazing cancer center
director that also works on the philanthropy side, and so some
of the funding that we've lost, we've been able to replace with
philanthropy from donors and individuals.
And we are even able, through the Leo Knudsen
Fund, to fund anywhere from people who need money to
support a funeral arrangement,
to, we provided funding for a fruit vendor who
needed to stop working because he needed chemo and
needed time to be able to do his therapy.
And so we're finding different ways, tied not
just to community organizations directly in the community, but
also through our donors and our other patients that
have been generous in helping us.
Thank you.
Thank you. That's amazing.
Great work. Thank you so much.
Any other questions? Okay. Thank you.
And
now we'll hear from Annie Ellis, who will tell us about a project that
she's been working on that engages patients...
A project that involves patient engagement.
Yes.
So,
thank you for the kind introduction, Patty, and it has just been such an honor to
be a part of this inspiring panel. I've been taking notes, and I can't wait to
get back and think about it. But, thank you to
AACR, the program committee, and sponsors for this
opportunity to share our work, "Partnership and Purpose to Maximize
Patient Research Advocate Involvement in Collaborative Preclinical
Research." So we're switching gears a little bit.
I'm going to tell you a little bit about Cancer Grand Challenges, and patient
advocacy within Cancer Grand Challenges, a little bit about
Matchmakers, and then how we were trying to increase
patient advocate involvement in basic science.
I have nothing to disclose.
So first, Cancer Grand Challenges is a global research
initiative funded by Cancer Research UK and NCI to support
interdisciplinary teams working on the toughest challenges in cancer
research. All Cancer Grand Challenges teams have patient
advocate team members.
The involvement of people with lived experience with cancer is required on Cancer
Grand Challenges teams to ensure that the work translates into
meaningful impact for people affected by cancer.
Over 70 patient advocates have been involved on 21 teams,
guided by Cancer Grand Challenges' Advocacy Panel, which is comprised
entirely of patient advocates.
Research advocacy and patient involvement are also important to Cancer Research
UK and the NCI.
I ran into Doug Lowy at breakfast this morning, and I told him I was going to use
this quote. I use this quote in all of my presentations
about
research advocacy and an overview of the history and what
we do. And one thing I always say is, "Well, Doug Lowy
said we're supposed to challenge you, so that's why we're challenging."
And,
so some patient advocates have professional research and medical
backgrounds, and many do not.
We know that patient advocates wear many different hats, patient support,
navigation, education, community outreach and awareness,
policy and legislative, fundraising, and social media.
All types of patient advocacy are essential, and advocates with
different cancers and different advocacy specialties are
represented across all Cancer Grand Challenge teams.
The term patient research advocates will be used throughout this presentation
because we bring real-world experience of patients and our communities
to research teams.
Oh, wrong way.
And just to kind of level set here,
many of the words describing advocacy activities are used
interchangeably. In Cancer Grand Challenges, we use the Cancer
Research UK definitions of PPI. PPI is
patient and public involvement in research.
And in broad strokes, PPI falls into three main buckets.
Participation, which means the clinical trial participants.
Engagement, which is sharing research out towards the public and
patients. And involvement-Patients as partners who bring
lived experiences into research dialogues.
Some of you in the SSP program will appreciate this little arrow
here, and this is the space that we'll be focusing on in this
talk.
So Team Matchmakers is an international team of cancer immunologists,
structural biologists, engineers, and computer scientists from the
US, Germany, United Kingdom, Netherlands, and Norway.
You can see our PIs down here, and there's about 50 to 60 trainees.
It fluctuates based on where they are in their
education. The four members of the Patient Advocate Committee are from the
US and Brazil.
So the team is using large-scale sequencing and structural
data sets to develop new experimental and computational
tools. Team Matchmakers is working together to make T-cell
receptor-based therapies more predictable,
programmable, and widely accessible, so more people can
benefit from precision cancer immunotherapy.
So in a nutshell, they want to increase the understanding of how the
T-cell receptors are activated so that they can
engineer more matches to ignite the immune system.
So patient involvement as partners in cancer
clinical trial design is becoming more and more commonplace, and often
there are tangible impact,
such as identifying and reducing barriers to accrual,
increasing acceptance of optional biopsies.
However, we hear that many experienced advocates,
especially
some people in this room,
but those that don't have a professional research or medical background,
do not feel a similar level of involvement with basic
science teams. And since the research question
is already set,
and the work of Matchmakers is completely preclinical,
we had to think differently to find ways to maximize how we were going to be
involved with the team in ways that were meaningful.
So we feel that we had some goals, and our main goal is to increase the
patient centricity of the research.
We meet
monthly with Matchmakers leadership, which is the lead PI and the program
manager, and leadership ensures that our inclusion,
that we're just in every single monthly team research meetings, the
PI meetings, and they empower us to plan our own
patient advocate session during the internal summits, which happen
annually. They also help identify and facilitate additional
opportunities to interact with trainees in smaller group settings,
and it's these smaller group settings which provide the space for deeper
bidirectional conversations.
So one of the first things we did was we met with the trainees to get to know each
other on a personal level and to discuss and prioritize potential
projects.
As a result, we're co-creating engagement deliverables that
are meaningful to both the advocates and the trainees.
These include a glossary, lay summaries, articles, and videos to
increase understanding of the work of Matchmakers for patient
communities and advocates. Some of the ways that we're thinking
differently is with our lab visit videos.
We want to go beyond pipettes and centrifuges.
The patient advocates wanted to showcase the people who do science,
that they're passionate, and to show collaborations that move science
forward. Our trainees wanted to
include the collegiality of working in a lab and
that science can be fun.
We also began to appreciate that cancer health
literacy is probably a prerequisite to patient advocacy and
research, and we really want to be involved in helping to educate and
empower survivors and advocates in Brazil, a low-middle income
country, to take their efforts to the next level.
The result of frequent involvement is bidirectional learning.
Advocates have gained increased understanding of the different projects and how the
parts fit together, and that is essential for us to identify
opportunities to infuse patient perspectives into the work.
Another result is that trainees report being impacted by the involvement with the
advocates. So many instruments that measure effectiveness
of patient advocate involvement in research teams seem too long, too
detailed, and focused on satisfaction of the involvement,
mostly at the end of the project, and it didn't fit our situation of really
building new relationships. So as a starting point, we created a simple
low-burden survey to measure trainees' experiences with the
advocates before and after joining Matchmakers.
As shown in the pie charts, awareness of patient advocates in research
was increased. So did frequency of the
interactions and impact of that involvement.
We have results here from about half of our trainees,
and we're hoping that in the future, we can get a higher response rate.
But one of the things that we are really happy about is that
the reflections that they provided in the comment section.
These comments were mostly related to the purpose
of their work, how it was going to translate, how it was going to help people, even
though that was going to be very long into the future.
They also reported better communication with non-scientists.
And while these impacts seem less tangible than you do for a
clinical trial, you can show that
accrual has increased. We believe that this is very meaningful,
and it connects basic science with the purpose of helping humankind.
We feel that it's profound and possibly long-lasting, and we're
hoping that by interacting with patient advocates, it may
help retain future leaders in the field of cancer.Our
hypothesis is that the people who
have more frequent interaction with us are also the people who are
significantly impacted because the pie,
it's the same amount. But
seems kind of obvious, but I think because we're dealing with scientists, you need
the data, and you need to collect it to prove it, and to get people to
buy on, and to be on board, and to normalize patient advocate
involvement in basic science.
So, in conclusion, we believe that partnership with leadership was
the key. The strong support and facilitation of
robust patient advocate involvement activities created an environment
of mutual respect and trust. This empowered advocates to fulfill
our role and purpose of increasing patient-centered scientific
thinking. Next steps include expanding the partnerships across all
Matchmaker institutions and working with patient advocate colleagues
across Cancer Grand Challenge teams to develop a best practice for
increasing meaningful involvement in pre-clinical research.
So, I thank you for your kind attention.
I thank you to all our colleagues on Team Matchmakers, Cancer Research
UK, NCI, and the Mark Foundation for Cancer Research who make this work
possible. I also want to thank Pfizer for sponsoring this session and
allowing us to get together and share our information with you, and
for sponsoring this amazing Amplify Humanity quilt that I'm so touched
by, by Joseph Thatchers. If you haven't seen it in the
patient advocate lounge area, please go see it.
It is quite stunning.
And there's a copy of our poster. Thank you very much.
We'll take any questions if anybody wants to walk up to the microphone.
So Annie, this is amazing. I think, I'm one that
really thinks that advocates really need to be more involved in that
basic preclinical, call it preclinical,
that's very nice,
research, because I think that people feel they aren't prepared.
So, has there been resistance for some advocates coming on
board? How many advocates have you been able to recruit?
Yeah.
In endeavors?
Yeah, we're looking to bring...
We had one European advocate who was ill and had to drop off the team,
so we actually have,
our internal summit this year is going to be in Norway later this year.
So one of our goals is to recruit an advocate.
We're having an advocate meeting too, because we're hearing from our
colleagues that
they want to be more involved in the basic science
in Norway. So we're bringing some people together, and hopefully out of
this meeting, we can bring one more on our team.
But yes, I think, in other
lives, in other research spaces,
people find that it is hard to... People are scared.
Can I bring my slides back up? I've got one towards the end.
Yeah, just click one more time. So, when I talk with a lot of people, I talk
about how can we bring people close together, and especially in
the basic science space. And scientists speak in the language of
data, and advocates speak in the language of hope.
And one of the things that research advocates
do is we bring our desires and our hopes
to the research teams, and then we go back and we take the data,
and we tell our communities what this means to us.
And, I call this my care and feeding of researchers and advocates, and
just a couple of top needs, but also our basic responsibilities.
But it's really important to build these relationships so that we can
have bidirectional communication, and that's where the learning comes
from. Then we can...
That's good. Thank you, Annie.
Put that away. Thank you.
And so we're going to open this up for general discussion now.
So, if you have questions for any of our panelists, that anything's piqued your
interest. And I think,
every time I hear other people speak about what they're doing, I'm like, "Oh, I
need to do that. Oh, I need to do that."
I don't know if everybody's feeling the same way, but I really feel like
I like how this panel is very
diverse and where they are seeing their patient advocacy happen from
basic research to a new clinical trial that's very
innovative. And then the community and patient engagement at comprehensive
cancer centers or any cancer center.
I think that's one thing that we're struggling with, how do we get more advocates
in cancer centers engaged? And then a grassroots
effort that's really, really cool. And, dealing...
I love biospecimens, and I think biospecimens are where the rubber hits the
road, and that we really need to move cancer forward.
So if anybody wants to come in and ask any questions, for now.
I think an unmet need is the cancer in the aging
community, in the rural community.
Mm-hmm.
And we have not engaged enough in that community
to bring about some synergy as far as getting them involved with
researchers and clinicians. So, do you have any thoughts about
that?
Anybody on the panel?
That was the cancer and aging?
Yes.
Yeah.
Well, I think there's the card, and the scoreboard.
And they've had a publication just come out, not too long ago.
But if you're of a certain age...
No, but, until a few, not too long ago, if
you were over 55,
you might've been excluded from some clinical trials because you were considered a
senior, and too old and not healthy.
And I think,
it's people who
advocated that we need more real-world population
in the clinical trials, that we were able to move the number
... the needle a little bit, and part of that was Friends of Cancer Research
broadening eligibility, who we have an author on the
panel. But
it takes advocacy and it takes talking about it, and if anybody is
in the room from a rural,
is considered a rural advocate, please come see me, because I've been
asked by someone to try to identify some rural advocates.
Yeah, and I think cancer and aging is really important, especially for clinical
trials.
And I think, the
geriatric assessment, I think, should be used more often than it
is to assess how.
So, everybody goes by age, but it's not by age.
And so getting more older adults on clinical trials
is really important to an underserved population,
and it's the most common population in cancer.
And a lot of my advocates are older, so we get a lot of input on
that. But yeah.
Go with the next question.
Hi, thanks for everything you've shared today.
I want to pick up on your point of we all keep having this, "Oh my God, we should
do that."
What if we did do that? What if we almost created our own
registry of, in all of our programs, this is the one thing that we
have found to be most successful. This is how we've created a
framework and shared that out with the community. What might that look like?
If each of you could share, do you have a thought on how we could
contribute that together?
Yeah, like best practices, type of thing.
And I think, a lot of times, all of our advocacy is by
organ site, right? But we all do the same thing.
And so yeah, that's a great idea. I don't know how to-
It sounds like a committee for next year.
There we go. Yeah, but I think it needs an honest broker to
kind of bring it together, and I think it needs to take
sharing. I work at a public
institution, and even though we have an anonymous link, the person
that made it for me said, "No, this should be public."
But we haven't gotten permission to do that, but it is pretty much public.
But, I think that sharing like that is really
important,
and that's why I did the poster, actually, to share what we do.
And we actually,
me and Jennifer, talk to a lot of different cancer centers, actually,
about this. And we actually did a--
So the COEs have an annual meeting, Community
Impact. I don't know what the other Cs stand for at CCCIF.
And they have an annual meeting, and we actually gathered advocates,
community members and advocates from every cancer center that
attended and did a virtual brainstorming on what is
meaningful advocacy. And so we're going to build on that and build
a framework of how do you do advocacy within a
comprehensive cancer center, and what do the patient and community members expect
from that type of thing. So we're working on certain things, but
I think it's going to take a lot of coordination.
Thanks. Maybe that's a different COE, the Center of Excellence.
Oh, yeah.
Hi. This has been such a great session.
So one of the points that came up is having or involving
advocates early on in the research process, and I think you talked
about having all the grants that are reviewed by advocates.
Mm-hmm.
Sort of if you guys could speak more about that and what kind of feedback you're
getting, what kind of feedback you're seeking from
advocates, and how you sort of put that into practice.
So I'll go first, and then I think
Kim can probably go. But we honed it down.
We talked with our scientists, and we talked with our advocates on what
should they be reviewing, how should they be reviewing, and things like that.
And we have scientists that look at the science, and we
really want our advocates to be super involved.
So we have one criteria that they do.
They say, "What is the impact on
patients and/or the community?" Because we do pop sci grants
as well as basic grants, so we span the thing. And that's what they look at.
And what the scientists are looking for is, is this worthwhile for
us to fund? Is it something that patients see as
important for them or the community?
And so that's what we do at Lineberger. I don't know how others do it.
So we have an RFP, and we have a group of very savvy
patient advocates who help review grants.
I think one's right in this room, John Warner, he is one of our reviewers.
And he actually reviews the entire grant.
But we do ask for questions like, how will
this go into the clinic, right? How many times our patients have to go to the
clinic? How many times do they have to go for blood draws?
How many times do they have-- When we're thinking about how many times patients
have to go in, right?
Really getting their feedback on how that would impact patients' lives
and what kind of roles.
If I could
respond from the rare cancer and pediatric cancer community.
For a small nonprofit like Cure MEC that my wife and I
formed,
we are the review committee, we're everything.
We're the fundraisers, and so imagine while we're dealing with
a very sick child and trying to frantically raise money
because there's no money going towards
finding treatments for our disease.
Once we started to raise a little bit of money and entice researchers with that
money,
people started to come to us with proposals.
They all sounded great to us.We learned our lesson early on
by funding some work that didn't really go where we wanted it to
go,
by beginning to more professionalize our approach, bringing in our scientific
advisory board, Cory Painter and Jane Wilkinson.
And they were able to actually help to
review proposals. So we were involved.
Everything sounded great to us, but at the end of the day, we've had to
even say no to some proposals because the
experts said, "You know what? The limited money you have should probably not go to
this effort that's going to take 10 years to come to fruition when you're trying to
save your son today."
Mm-hmm. Thank you.
I just wanted to add that one of the things that we're trying to do is
involve the patient advocates from conceptualization of the
research idea. So it's not just coming to us when they have the
proposal already written, but when they're conceptualizing the
idea and the meaning of the idea or the impact that it could have
and how will that get back to the information into the
communities that are going to be researched on.
And so trying to make that link. And at one point, we even
did
a bus tour where we brought together the
researchers, basic scientists, with our community
partners and went on a bus around the neighborhoods
where they were recruiting their patients from so that
they can really see what the lives of these people are
like. So when they're conceptualizing an idea and
having a question, how many times does it take you to get in to be
seen,
they try to understand what are the conditions that people live
in. And so starting from the conceptualization of a
brilliant research idea and the practicality of it is
really key too.
Yeah, I think that's where I want to go, is pre anything's written, just
coming up with the best ideas as a group of advocates and researchers
trying to do that. That's kind of one of my goals.
But it's a stepwise process.
I'll just add one thing. We have a really amazing grant process, and we actually
have a scoring.
Yeah.
So the doctors, the
researchers, the patient advocate, they get to rate, and then we review
it all. So it's kind of a neat process.
Yeah, that's what we score.
Yeah.
Hi. Thanks so much for the work that you're doing and excuse me, for sharing.
It's just amazing across different perspectives and what you're doing.
I work in sarcoma patient advocacy, and I feel like we've gotten
more buy-in for including the patient voice.
People now say, "We want to have that patient voice as part of research." And
I think it's been easier in clinical research to find
touch points and inflection points where patient advocates and the
perspective can be really helpful.
I'm really curious if we can kind of flesh out a little bit more about the
basic research. Basic researchers are like, "We really want
to engage people, but we just don't know how to do that." I think we,
as a community, are trying to learn how to do it, and I think we have
to help them understand how we can help, because when you look at many of the
NIH type grants, grants anywhere, they want you to put a
patient advocate on there. And so we want to be good partners and really make
a contribution, and I think we're struggling a little bit more with how to do that,
especially in the space of basic research.
So if you have additional thoughts, I would love to hear it. Thank you.
Yeah. I can tell you some of the things.
I think one of the things we struggle with, and I think she's going to ask the
question, is how do you measure impact, right? Especially in basic research.
I'm not going to tell you what mouse to use. Not going to happen. Right?
And so what is that
role that you play? And I was on a
PO1
that never got funded, but we talked a lot, and we got to know the basic
researchers, and one of the basic researchers now is very engaged,
and she invited people to her lab, to view her
lab and visit her lab, and I think some
advocates and patients have never been to a research lab.
And just doing that kind of opens the door for
communication and really forming those relationships, too.
And as they move into different things, they have a connection with someone
that actually had the disease. Also, I went to a lab
meeting. I go to lab meetings regularly, but I went to a different lab
meeting of someone working on vaccines, and his
lab just grilled me. I did a vaccine clinical trial, and they just grilled
me on, "Well, what made you decide? How did you do it? Was it good?
Was it bad?"
Different things, because they're at the basic bench level, but they're working on
something that will get into patients, and they never see patients.
And so that was kind of interesting as well.
And to your point of measuring benefit, because I think that was the question I
was going to ask before, and you had raised how you actually asked the
trainees what the impact, and I think that's going to be critical that we continue
to collect some data to feed back and
share how does it make a difference, because I think that will help all of us
engage some of our basic researchers and clinical researchers as well
and show that we're not trying to usurp their space.
No.
We're never going to know all that they know, but we do have something
valuable that we can bring to the table.
Yeah. And I think also in communication.
I speak at the Trainee Day research thing.
I speak twice in T32 RNRs on
communication.
Yeah.
We can really help them do that. We can really help them.
I edit lay abstracts all the time, but I teach
them how to edit their own lay abstracts, right?
And so I think that doing that so that as they grow
up in their field of whatever, they become really
good at writing lay abstracts, then writing for the public,
speaking to the public, things like that.
That's one of the things that I think we can really help with as patient advocates
Yeah. One thing that I think that is missing, that we could ask more
of, is even for the... We know there are spaces
where there are researchers who get it.
Who know how to engage with us, who have been
successful, and there have been impacts.
I think we need to ask the researchers how they've been
impacted, what they've learned from us, how that's changed them, and get that out
there more, so that as we can get further
away from the
bedside and into the bench,
and then start showing what these impacts are.
This is what I learned. This is how it may be better.
I actually started to do this work at the Cancer Grand
Challenges summit last month, and I was asking some of the
researchers, "So,
what have you learned?"
Because this is what I think is missing.
And someone said to me, "I learned how to talk to
non-scientists, and I was up for a
job. And because I had been
involved with advocates, I was able to explain my work to
people who were not in my field." And she got the job.
So,
not everyone's going to have that story, but we need to collect stories.
We need to-
Mm-hmm.
... show the examples of why this works and what our value is.
Great. Thank you very much.
Yeah, because we survey our advocates, which is really easy, but we surveyed the
researchers, not so easy. So they're being interviewed, but
it's really qualitative.
But we have to deal with that and figure out how to make that into a story.
I was just going to add, we... Oh, sorry, didn't mean to scream.
We have researchers who do lab tours for our advocates all the time.
I literally just saw a mouse colonoscopy, which was the
craziest thing ever. When they're testing new drugs, it was
crazy. So we have those opportunities for our patient advocates to go and
actually see the research being done. So I think that's pretty amazing.
Yeah.
If I could just add that I think our patient advocates can really make a
difference in training our researchers as well.
I had the experience of meeting with one of our researchers who was studying
circadian rhythm in flies, and the implications of
sleep in cancer, and you can imagine that's a
long bridge. And
trying to meet with our patient advocates to try to understand what this research
meant and what it's going to eventually.
And it was such an eye-opener for the researcher himself to
realize the importance of what he was doing,
not just at a very basic clinical level, but
also in terms of what it was going to mean for people who
may have night jobs and cancer and things like that.
And that connection had not been made until they met with the patient
advocates, and so that makes a big difference.
Yeah, and then the other way, we had a fruit fly guy too.
Give a talk to our patient advocates, and
one of our advocates had an email exchange with him, said, "I have a
newfound appreciation of fruit flies."
It was quite spectacular to see the
connection. Anyhow, yeah. Last question.
Advocacy registry.
There's been a growth in all nonprofit organizations that
promoting advocate and scientist relationship.
There are more
definite special areas where they're looking for underserved.
There's such a broad depth that has grown over the last five
years. Why have we not created yet a national
advocacy registry
whereby not only organizations could find
advocates, but also scientists and researchers could find
advocates, or projects could find advocates?
Mm-hmm. Yeah, because that's the big step that's missing. Yeah.
That's a hard one.
Okay. We'll help you design that.
Yeah.
I think it's hard, too, because each-
Okay, thank you so much, everyone who came. Thanks for Pfizer.
Thanks for ACR- ... for really valuing the patient input.
And hope to see you next year. So,
thank you.
Thanks,
guys.